e
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Herkese merhaba
O benim adım ömrünü Sofia sanatla
ilgileniyorum on yılı aşkın bir süredir
yurtiçinde ve yurtdışında çeşitli sanat
kalelerinde fuarlarda müzelerde
sergilenmektedir
ipimi gücün Tanrısı olarak bilinen
herkülü modern Dünyaya adapte ettiğim
bir sanatın var
ve
ortaokul bilgisayarlarında böyle
dersleri Maske ve çizimlerle doluydu
öyle dersi çok derste dinleyen bir çocuk
değildim yazılı ve ezbere dayalı
şeylerde adam çok yoğunluğu içinde
okulumu okul sondan üçüncü olarak
bitirdim
bugün cesaretimi çok kırıcı Ben kendime
karşı çok düştüm yani Avukat işte ne
bileyim mühendisi Doktor olamayacaktır
Bugün beni dinleyen ve kendine karşı
dürüst olan herkesin çok şanslı olduğunu
söyleyebilirim Tabii insan kendi şansını
kendi yazıyor buna geleceğiz Ama kendine
karşı dürüst olmak ne demek ben biraz
ondan bahsedeceğim size
Ama ben bunu iki ayırıyorum birincisi
kendi kimliğimize karşı olan düştüğümüz
İkincisi de fikirlerimiz olan düştüğümüz
sana ben de fikir adamıyım ve hayatımı
iki fikirlerimi görsele dökerek
yaşıyorum özgürlüğü Fikri gücüne çok
inanıyorum
bugün özgürlüğü Fikri olmayan biri onu
pazarlamaya kalkarsa eminim bir yerde
patlayacaktır yerde çıkacak karşına
Ağabey hani senin fikrini yakışıklı
yapılmış var diyecektir
işte bu noktada biraz cesaretten de
bahsetmem lazım Çünkü o Özgün fikre
ulaşmak için cesaret de bize gerekiyor
illaki dönüşsüzdür a bunu kesin
yapmışlardır sana gelene kadar
öteki yapmışlarsa
Ve siz bunu yapacak kadar kendinize söz
ediyor musunuz ya da hayatınızı o
inandığınız Çünkü arayacak kadar cesur
musunuz
Ya ben şanslı çocuktum beni çok Özgür
yetişen ebeveynlere sahiptim çocukluk
odamın duvarı tuvalim gibiydi her şeyi
yazıyordum çiziyordum resimlerle
boyuyordum da denemekten asla
çekinmiyorum
Belki de ben o yüzden özgü bir çocuk
olarak geçtim
Evet şimdi İnsan kendi kiminle karşı
dürüst olduğunda hayatta nerede
durduğunda daha iyi şekillendirebiliriz
zor mesela Eğer sesinizi değilse bir
şarkıcı olamazsınız ya da işte kan
görmeye dayanamıyor sanız işte Genel
Cerrah olamazsınız ve ben de kendime
karşı çok görüştüm ben ne olamayacağımı
biliyordum ama daha önemli şey var ne
olacağını biliyordum ve hayatımda hep
plana Sadık kaldım başladık İnsan kendi
şansını kendi yaratır İşte bu şansı
yaratabilmek için böyle bir plana
ihtiyacım var Çünkü o plan sayesinde
hayatta nerede durdunuz o şansın nerede
beklediğinizi şekilde duruyor Ben
sorarım size işte Sizce o şansın
gelmesini Umudumuz yerde mi
bekliyorsunuz
Ben size kendi sanatkarin şekillendiren
bir olaydan bahsetmek istiyorum bir
koleksiyonlarım beni Londra'ya davet
etti tanışmak üzere Benim için de çok
güzel bir fırsat 3. Ben daha şehirde
önce görmüştüm numarayı gittim
kendisiyle tanıştım eserim hakkında ve
Sanat hakkında biraz konuştuk akabinde
daha sonra randevulaşmak üzere ayrıldık
işte turistik açıdan bir fırsattır
Londra'yı daha önce görmüştüm elimde cep
telefonum işte haritalara bakarak olsak
senin bu Sokak benim geziyorum
bir ara New on Strike adında bir sokağa
saptım
like ve yorum ki bu uluslararası anlamda
neredeyse hayran kaldım bütün sanatçılar
ve onları temsil eden çok çok iyi
geceler hepsi aynı sokakta konumlanmış
Evet şimdi işimiz sanatı öğretmek
olduğunda böyle bir ortam hakikaten
tüyleriniz diken diken ediyor ama biraz
da sizi ürkütüyor çünkü seviyenin nerede
olduğunu gördünüz biraz korkuyorsunuz
açacağız ama hiç unutmam O zaman ben
şöyle bir şey demiştim kendi kendime ne
ya eğer Dünyada böyle bir ortam varsa Ve
ben bunu dahil değilse Martı küfür
etmesen de olur ha Çünkü benim gözlerim
buraya gördüm
bu Ve sanırım şanslıydım
farkındaydım doğru zamanda doğru yerde
din ve adım atma cesaretinde
sahipliğinde adım attım Ne yaptın
birader içeri girdim
bir tesadüf bu ya
Daha önce acaba ya bu adam benden mi
esinlenmiş dediğim bir sanatçının işi
duruyor karşında iş gerçekten benim
işime çok benziyor bu uzun işe bakar
oldum ve ata bin de daha sonradan
galerinin müdürü olduğunu öğrendim ki
bilmiyorum a geldi koleksiyon el Siz
herhalde de çünkü hep ilgilendiğiniz
görmüş dedi Ben de hayır dedim ben
koleksiyon elimden sanatçıyım ve işin
Aslında bu işin benim işlemine kadar
benzetme bakıyordum deyince Tabii adam
bir şaşırdı dedi sizin işiniz derken
dedi
diyarından Çok uzun süredir size Herkül
temalı heykeller yatırım Yoo eserlerinde
bilirim dediğimde
bu Londra'nın göbeğinde
hiç tanımadığımız sokakta hiç
tanımadığım bir galeride tanımadığım bir
adam böyle adamı da biraz yanlış
telaffuz ederek ya siz Türk sanatçı Emre
Yusuf ya olabilir misiniz dedi bana
bu Vallahi her şeyin değiştiği sıfır
noktası Tam da o an dış Çünkü fark ettim
ki bazı şeyler zaten olmuş ben
Bağcılar'dan beğenmişim sadece kaldır
kıçını gidip Merhaba benim adım Yusuf
İslam kalmış
E tabii çok motive oldum
ve bu motivasyonla işte Oradan çıktım
şıma Aslında keşke şurada sergilendiği
bir başka Galeri vardı oraya girdim
bu ve kendimden çok daha Emin Öz güvenli
bir şekilde dedim ki ben galerinin
müdürle görüşmek istiyorum Bir hanfendi
geldi bugün dedi dedim Ben bir
sanatçıyım sizin dediğiniz çok beğendim
sizinle çalışmak istiyorum
o da şaşırdı Hay hay tabi dedi ama hani
yandan da da nasıl olacak işte oturduk
işlerini gösterdim ve
işlemini göstereceğim buraya özellikle
dikkat çekmek istiyorum işlerini çok iyi
hazırlamış olduğu Instagram profili
üzerinden gösterdim bu İnstagram
profilime hazır olması kontrol şöyle
birşey insan şans ayağına geldiğinde
hazır olmalı Ben de şans ayağıma geldi
hazırdım ve
en iyi hazırlamış olduğum portfolyomu
kendisine en iyi şekilde gösterebilirim
hazırlığın kime yapımı çok önemli yok
bence
ne konuştuk
vedalaştık akabinde Bundan sonra ne
olacak diye sordum işte dedi ki Eğer
sizin için her şeyi geçerse
size bir mail gelecek dedi ki İstanbul'a
döndüm olmaya geldi
galerinin
adını veren adını taşıyan soyadı olan
birinden gelmişti olmayı ve
diyordu ki geleyim izin sahibi Sizinle
tanışmak üzere ve belki çalışmak üzere
Sizi parça da artıyor
O çok şükür sevmişim aşırı mutlu
olmuştum ve koşarak farz ettim hiç
beklemedim ve Paris'te gördüm dedin
orada gördüm ben bir daha güzel içeri
girdim Emre Hoş geldiniz Yani insanlar
beni karşıladı hiç tanımadığım insanlar
ve insan o an sanata verilen değer hemen
anlıyor şu üst kata çıktım şehitlerim
yapılmış Yani bütün eserlerini asılmış
halde galerinin sahibi beni bekliyordu
Uzun lafın kısası
bi artık dünyanın ilk kalelerinden
birini çalışıyorum onlarla Onlar
tarafından temsil ediliyor
bugün belki
ve o adımı atma cesaretine sahip olmasam
karşınızda olmaya gidelim Ben bu hikaye
de bunu çok çalışma yayılmaya vb Azimli
olmaya borçluyum diyemeyeceğim Ama şunu
söyleyebilirim
özgürlüklere sahip olmama kendine karşı
dürüst olmamak
bu ne Cesur olan borçluyum diyebilirim
o zaman Eskisinden Çok Daha değerli ve
O hep derler yaşlı insanı yeter ki
istesin
çalışsın her şey olur benim Bunu biraz
yok hemen şöyle diyorum
İnsan önce kendine karşı dürüst olsun
Evet çalışsın Sonra her şey değil ama
doğru şey olsun ve proje kendi şansını
kendi yaz ben dilinizin çok teşekkür
ederim